- Hey copper jockey, how
much you made today, huh?
30 cents?
- 45, actually.
- Oh, 45 cents, huh?
Here's 50, keep the
change, you filthy animal.
(laughs)
Hey Penny Lane, I'm talking to you.
You know what I can't figure out?
Why we take our best president
and put him on the most shit coin.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
- [Quarters] So this girl comes
up to me, right, new girl.
Apparently in charge of making the--
- You guys mind if grab a
little lunch here with ya?
- [Quarters] Yeah, have a seat.
- You heard him.
- So anyways, this girl
says she's in charge
of the $2 bills, right.
(laughs)
- Satisfying.
(clears throat)
- Who the hell are you?
(intense music)
- Please don't.
- That was really good.
(groaning)
- Not you, you get the fuck out of here.
(high-pitched whistling)
Hey man.
- You ever keep up with Nickel
and Dimes, are those guys?
- I haven't seen 'em for awhile,
they stopped returning my calls.
- You were kind of a jerk.
- Yeah, I'm sorry about that,
I really kinda let the responsibility--
- Water under the bridge.
Oh don't worry about
it, I got it, I got it.
Oh.
- We don't have any bitcoins.
- Yeah, we actually used to
work at the Mint together.